and before we start discussing
philosophy and the human soul house
money has to work hi it's wonderful to
have this forum here I'm so excited I
actually started with a dinner we had in
Atlanta and the idea of bringing Dave
and Jordan Peterson here came about and
actually happened so I'm just gonna
introduce not take too much time of the
people standing here sitting here sorry
I'll start with Jordan Peterson dr.
Peterson is a professor at the
University of Toronto was nominated for
the prestigious Levinson teaching Prize
when he was a professor at Harvard and
is regarded by his current University of
Toronto students and colleagues as one
of three truly life-changing teachers
dr. Peterson is prominent a prominent
intellect international speaker and a
public personality Dave Rubin mr. Rubin
is a talk show host comedian and a TV
personality is the host of the Rubin
report a talk show about big ideas and
free speech
they've has been heralded for his person
but it politically incorrect an honest
approach to discussing complex issues
and current events focusing on politics
religion and the media dr. Ian Brooke is
the chairman of the board of the enuine
Institute and he's the co-author with
Don Watkins of the pursuit of wealth
equal is unfair in their national
bestseller of free market revolution in
2012 he is the host of the Iran Brooks
show on blog talk radio and Greg Salieri
dr. salmieri teaches philosophy at
Rutgers II Rutgers University
and he's a fellow at the anthem
foundation for Objectivist scholarships
and co security of the Iran Society he's
a co-editor of the companion to Iran in
the Blackwell companion to philosophy
series welcomed those for and one word
about the person who made it possible
generous board member of the INA
Institute and thank you to high ground
sorry high road productions for making
this happen so here we go
all right so first off to begin we are
live-streaming this on my channel and as
I'm sure many of you guys saw I was on
Joe Rogan's show a couple weeks ago and
we talked a little bit about objectivism
and he said that you guys are very
serious people that you're you're very
serious people so I need you guys to go
absolutely bananas for the thousands and
ultimately hundreds of thousands of
people that will be watching this at
home can you make some noise
look at you guys you crazy Objectivist
alright you're such an when you're such
a negative influence babe I've never
seen them like this last night last time
I didn't event with you guys we had the
whole audience screaming out George
Carlin 7 dirty work
that's true I don't know if we're gonna
do that at all ok so we're gonna do
about an hour and a half with you guys
and we're gonna throw in some Q&A it's
obviously completely uncensored and in
the spirit of free speech and
individuality that you guys are talking
about here at this conference
so Jordan we've been on tour now for
almost two months and we have a little
break right now but I thought why don't
we just dive right back into all the
things we've been talking about so much
of your your tour for your 12 rules for
life book has been about the role of the
individual so before we get too deep in
into philosophy and and some of the
other things I thought that would be the
right place to start because that's sort
of what unifies all four of us up here
yeah well I've been making the case I
suppose or or developing the argument
and this is an argument everybody knows
to some degree although I don't think
we've done a very good job of
articulating it over the last few
decades that you know it's it's no
secret that our free societies or the
free societies of the world are
predicated on the idea of the sovereign
individual right and that's that's the
that's the place where political power
ultimately resides or let's say
political authority but and it's also in
some sense the derivation source of the
idea of rights the fact that the
individual is sovereign the individual
has inalienable rights and we talked a
lot about rights in our society and way
too much as far as I'm concerned not
that they're not important but they're
secondary because the fundamental issue
of import with regards to individual
sovereignty isn't rights it's
responsibility I mean first of all you
could make a case that your rights are
my responsibility and vice versa
so there's a parallelism between rights
and responsibilities but even more
importantly if the intake
the state is dependent on the integrity
of the individual and and and that's the
argument that's implicit in the idea
that the individual is sovereign then
it's obviously the case that the
individual has a great responsibility
and it's a responsibility that's of
Incred incredible importance because
it's not just limited to you it's it's
you you acting responsibly actually
constitutes the bedrock of the state and
so so that's an interesting issue it
means that you're required in some sense
to take responsibility or the entire
state will shake and I think that's true
for everyone but more interestingly I
think this is a more interesting
argument in some sense is that you need
a meaning to sustain you through life or
you need meaning perhaps not AB meaning
you need meaning to sustain you through
life because life is bitterly difficult
and and and and an ultimately
challenging mortally challenging for
that matter and you need a meaning to
sustain you through that so that it
doesn't embittered you and turn you into
a victim let's say and it's pretty
obvious to me and I think obvious to
anyone when they think it through
that virtually everything that you
derive genuine meaning from and I mean
the kind of meaning that will sustain
you when times are difficult I don't
mean casual happiness even though
there's nothing wrong with happiness
what the the meaning that will sustain
you through the tragedy of life is
always to be found in the adoption of
responsibilities and the people that you
admire spontaneously and I don't think
there's an exception to this unless
you're a little on the psychopathic side
and I mean that technically you you feel
I do I mean I mean it technically it's
like it's a hallmark of psychopathy I
would say generally speaking you admire
yourself to the degree that you do when
you're at least taking care of yourself
at least that and maybe when you have a
little responsibility left over for your
family and maybe some to spill over for
the broader community and certainly the
people that you spontaneously admire in
your in your fellow men are people who
at minimum our accounting further
for the burden of themselves at minimum
that but then who have excess capacity
and devote that to the proper care of
their family in their community and so I
don't think that we've done a good job
of laying out the meaning equals
responsibility equation and it's it's
vitally important and I think it's very
helpful for people to learn that lots of
people have told me that that that you
know that they've been getting their
lives together and digging them out of a
selves out of a nihilistic and hopeless
hole and doing that by understanding
that the meaning they need to sustain
them is to be found through the adoption
of the maximum responsibility they can
sustain and so well that's that's become
clearer to me over the course of these
last let's say 50 lectures so Greg I saw
you nodding along there a lot can you
put some of this within an Objectivist
frame yeah well I mean not to plug but I
gave a talk that actually the event that
I met you act called taking
responsibility for your happiness I
think I have a bit of a different view
of happiness and you do and and Rann has
different when you then you do where
what I mean by happiness isn't the
transient joy or emotion you could feel
in a moment but the the state of being
the state of emotion that comes from
accomplishing achieving your values
having taken responsibility set yourself
goals and leading a life where you're
achieving those goals over time and I
think that's what ethics is about I
think that's what gives meaning to life
and I a really deep part of that is
taking responsibility for yourself I
would I a little bit bristle at the idea
of saying that responsibility is more
important than rights or the reverse I
think they're they're issues that come
up at a different tier so I think taking
responsibility for yourself as a matter
of ethics it's a matter of how you live
your own life it's a matter of how you
lead a life worth living and be happy
and have meaning I think those go
together but then rights are the
conditions that we need when we organize
as a society to make everybody able to
do that not to be in front impinging on
each other and if we don't all value our
own lines and happiness if we're not all
taking responsibility or at least if
many of us aren't we're not going to
have a society
cares about rights and they're gonna go
away and so in that sense I agree we
need to have this shift to talking about
ethics and what we want to make of our
lives each of us yeah I mean when we
talk about the individual I think one of
the points that needs that's important
to make is the individually supporting
partially because that's all we got
right in a sense all you got is
individuals we can talk about society
but society is just a collection of
individuals it's starting point both in
ethics and in politics has to be the
unit of value the unit that actually
exists the metaphysical value the unit
that exists not the abstraction that we
call the state or society what's
important is the ability of the
individual to live a good life to take
responsibility for his own life his own
happiness for his own success for his
own flourishing so the individual is is
is everything when it comes in my view
in morality and and and and then as an
extension in politics and I think rights
are the concept that recognize that is
it's the bridge rights of the bridge
between a morality that says your moral
responsibility is to make the most of
your life and then what kind of
political system should we live in Kent
should we live in to make that possible
and rights recognizes that the enemy of
the good life the enemy of flourishing
the enemy of success at living is
coercion and force it's it's the group
the states the the community are the
people other individuals cursing for
being authoritarian over you telling you
how you must live and how you must act
and rights recognize that as individuals
we have freedom we must be free to use
our own judgments to live our own lives
as we see fit and and that's the great
revolution of the Enlightenment is is
the recognition of the sanctity of the
individual and creating a political
system that allows the individual to
flourish and to thrive by protecting him
from coercion by protecting him for
force and and relegating the state to
that duty the responsibility of the
state is
patek rights to protect you from force
so it seems to me that the battle
between the individual and the
collective is a battle that has been
fought for virtually every Society for
all time however there does seem to me
at least and maybe it's just because I'm
alive right now and doing what I do that
there's something unique about the
battle at the moment that the individual
has been slammed so relentlessly and
that we have ideas out there now that
for for young people that they think
that socialism is cool I mean that seems
to be coming back right I mean these are
these are ideas that I think are really
crazy but I'm happy to indulge in in the
discussion about them do you think
there's anything unique about the the
battle between the individual and the
collective right now or is this just a
repeating of what's gone on I think I
think it's before I think I mean there's
always something unique about each
historical moment but I I think this is
this is been a continuous argument for
the last hundred and thirty years like
as a technical philosophical argument
and and of course it has roots that go
back much farther than that I don't see
I mean it is collectivism versus
individualism I think the fundamental
polarizing force that's that's it's
that's at work at the moment and the
issue with the collectivist types is
whether or not they're collectivist
because they care about the dispossessed
which is their fundamental claim or
whether they're collectivist because
they don't want to bear any of the
responsibilities that would go along
with being a responsible individual and
you know I'm always skeptical of the of
the saint-like moral claims that are put
forth by people who are pushing and
given ideology and now I'm skeptical
about that on my part two of the people
who criticized my perspective say look
dr. Peterson you're not or maybe they
call me something a lot less they say
you're not you're not you're you're
you're under estimating the degree to
which systemic barriers make it
impossible for people to move forward
properly in the world there's there's
barriers to the progress that people can
make even if they bare individual
responsibilities and those barriers are
distributed unequally and of course
there's some truth in that because
every system tends towards rigidity and
tyranny and no system does a perfect job
of selecting among its people for pure
competence but there's a difference
between saying that a system is somewhat
corrupt which is certainly the case with
Western systems and the system is an
absolutely corrupt tyrannical patriarchy
with no hope of redemption whatsoever it
needs to be burned to the ground and
reformulated those are really different
and you know it's it's also possible to
be sensible and say well look I mean
obviously the manner in which people are
selected for success in our society is
imperfect but also to know well
imperfect compared to what exactly like
to your hypothetical utopian perfection
which you would self generate if you
were given ultimate power because that's
really the comparison or to our
societies in the past because we're
doing a lot better now than we were or
compared to every other society that's
ever existed since the dawn of time by
which standard we're doing so insanely
well that it's actually almost
unbelievable and and this is another
thing that I've been trying to promote I
mean there's been at least a dozen books
written in the last six or seven years
by fairly serious scholars and I would
say distributed across the the the
political spectrum pointing out that
like ever since the year 2000 things are
getting better so fast that it's
actually a miracle you know and I can
give you some quick facts so the rate of
absolute poverty in the world fell by by
50 percent between the year 2000 and
2012 so that's a staggering achievement
it was three years faster than the most
optimistic projections of the UN so we
actually beat in optimistic UN
projection so there are more well that
submits absolutely beyond belief there
are more forests in in in the northern
hemisphere now than there were a hundred
years ago the child mortality rate in
Africa is now lower than it was in
Europe in 1950 which is just beyond
belief the fastest growing economies in
the world are in sub-saharan Africa
about 300,000 people I can't remember if
it's a day or a week but it doesn't
matter although it would be better if it
was a day obviously our being plugged
into the electrical grid so increasingly
people have universal access to fresh
water there's almost no country in the
world now where starvation is a problem
that isn't just a political problem
which is to say we have enough food for
everyone and not only do we have enough
food we have the distribution systems
that are actually getting that food to
everyone it's absolutely beyond belief
and what's what's quite remarkable about
that is it's quite obvious that
individually that like that free market
systems predicated on the idea of the
sovereignty of the individual are the
reason that that's happening so
so the question is what the hell are the
collectivists up to yeah why are they
like what's the problem here and the
problem the problem seems to be a
certain amount of ignorance a certain
amount of willful blindness and a
certain amount of discomfort with the
fact that a fair bit of that wealth has
been purchased at the price of a
continuing inequality we don't know how
to generate wealth without also
generating inequality and I actually
don't think that you can generate wealth
without generating inequality and that's
well that's something that's worth
endlessly discussing I think you're
allowed might have a little sign to say
about it yeah I mean I like to say in
brief write inequality is a feature of
freedom not a bug it just comes with
freedom you're absolutely right you
cannot create wealth without any
qualities and there's nothing wrong with
inequality there's nothing bad about
inequality there's nothing I've modeled
the offensive about inequality and in
particular given that what happens is
that everybody's getting richer hmm
everybody gets rich so they just get
rich at a different pace and the reason
they get rich at a different pace it's
because they're producing different
quantities of value the people who
actually get very rich in a free market
now we don't have a pure free market and
all kinds of problems with the system we
have but in a free market you only gain
those values that you produce Jeff visa
says that we is the richest person in
the world because how many of you shop
on Amazon everybody right so there's a
reason he's produced values that have
affected almost every human being on the
planet and and that's that that is why
he you know you're so wealthy so if the
whole inequality debate is is to try to
drive people towards envy the whole
inequality debate is to try to undercut
the the idea of freedom because what
they're really after is not would you
see inequality what they're really after
is eliminating freedom it's the same
people who used to advocate for an
ideology of communism or socialism now
that's been discredited so they have to
call it something else
Joe Stiglitz
the Nobel Prize winner in economics is
not gonna come out for communism but in
a sense he views that as the mall ideal
you can't get there it's rough there's a
little to violence too much blood for
his taste he's an economist after all
right so so inequalities are nice
disguise so we want to reduce inequality
and might debates with people who talk
about any quality say about how much
well well know when we get there who oh
now who gets to decide how we gonna vote
how much are we gonna take and why why
just monetary inequality I mean babes a
good-looking guy it's a lot of it's a
lot of hairspray man I mean how do how
do we how do we do that how do we you
know they've been experiments in trying
to equal us in the book we give the
example of course of the tragedy of the
horrific tragedy of Cambodia in the
Cameroon where the attempt is to
equalize not just not just on on
monetary issues but on smarts or the
only way to do that is to kill educated
in the smart on every other fact on
who's a good farmer and who's a good
good father for food they killed them
all 40 percent of the population it's
it's so yes the whole I mean it I get I
get really upset when people even make
an issue of inequality because it
shouldn't be an issue inequality and I
think it's changed I think in America 50
years ago and I'm not trying to be
nostalgic because I know the dangers in
that it just it there wasn't this I
nobody cared
right because there was this feeling
that you owned it you worked hard
you made it well there was also a
feeling that see I'm not so sure people
care as much about inequality as they
care about inequalities of hypothetical
trajectory so meaning that it isn't so
bad if you're rich and I'm poor if I
believe that if I put my best foot
forward I might also my life will
improve across time or even if mine
doesn't my children's life will because
I think people are more interested I
think people vote their dreams rather
than their reality and the dream has to
be intact and I do have a couple of just
one thing I think that's
true but it's also true that people
people resent wealth when they think is
unearned yeah I think the more the more
we move towards a centrally planned
economy the more we have cronyism the
more their real problems and the kind of
the mixed economy that we have we don't
have pure capitalism then the more
they're suspicious of the people at the
top because indeed they see the people
at the top
schmoozing with the politicians and
that's what scares them so I think
America shipped that partially because
they're not sure that people have earned
it and partially because they've been
bombarded with this message you should
envy them it's it's Amal inequality so I
think it's a combination the combination
of the dream the justice of it is it
just for somebody to have to have that
wealth because they've earned it and
this issue of they've just there's been
a shift in the morality in the in the
mall perception I think we have a we
have a structural problem that's going
to emerge to that and and this is where
I would take some issue I suppose with
the with the idea that there's nothing
intrinsically bad about inequality I
mean because it presumes something
approximating a level playing field and
I'm not thinking so much about systemic
barriers well let me just make the
argument very briefly if you tell me
what you think because one of the things
that I spend a lot of time looking at
what predicts success in in in Western
and functional Western hierarchies and
the to intrinsic psychological factors
that predict success are intelligence as
you assess it with IQ tests which is the
best way to assess intelligence by by by
an overwhelming margin and trait
conscientiousness which is
industriousness and orderliness
sometimes known as grit and those are
quite good predictors of long-term
success they account for about 40% of
the variability across time which leaves
a lot of other factors still at play but
there's something quite terrifying about
the intelligence end of that equation
because IQ is is normally distributed in
the population and there's incredible
differences between people who are at
the top of the IQ distribution and
people who are at the bottom like it you
can't believe how
variable people are in their
intelligence it's quite staggering well
I can give you an example so it's
actually illegal in the United States to
induct someone into the Armed Forces if
they have an IQ of less than 83 and the
reason for that is that they Armed
Forces determined after a hundred and
some years of extraordinarily rigorous
testing motivated by the hope that
everyone would be fodder for the Armed
Forces because that's their hope right
because they have a chronic manpower
shortage peacetime and wartime so they
want people in the Armed Forces they're
not going to exclude them unless they
have to and the consequence of the
analysis was that if you have an IQ of
83 or less there isn't anything you can
be trained to do in the Armed Forces
that isn't positively counterproductive
it's like yes yes and this is a way
bigger fact than you think because
that's about 10 percent of the
population and so so we have a problem
and and I would say it's a problem that
is is going to manifest itself in
something that approximates a and
inequality that looks unfair because
there are the cognitively dispossessed
are going to have a very rough time
competing they already do I mean there's
there's absolutely no doubt about that
and so it it see the problem with with
producing hierarchies and even allowing
people to climb up the hierarchies
responsibly is that the hierarchy still
produce dispossession at the bottom and
we need to figure out how to deal with
that even if the only consequence of
that dispossession is the generation of
envy because envy can bring down the
state and you might tell people while
you have a moral responsibility not to
be envious and fair enough perhaps you
do but it isn't clear that that's going
to be sufficient solution to solve the
problem and we also have the cognitive
problem that no one will talk about and
that we should talk about because it's a
real it's real well so it sounds like
we're talking about the same thing
whether we're talking about it from a
cognitive perspective or a financial
perspective that in terms of inequality
it's not really the all the people sort
of at the bottom but it's the it's the
bottom of the bottom that can't help
themselves that seems like maybe what do
you do about that
one point that Rand made about this and
I think making this point is part of the
solution to to people being envious
letting people internalize this point is
that other people's goodness other
people's accomplishments other people's
intelligence other people's wealth if
they've earned it and a society that
enables the most productive smartest
people to achieve what they can achieve
is good for everyone and especially good
for the people at the bottom of whatever
hierarchy we might be talking about of
whatever level of ability whatever level
of money and we can see that in giving a
little bit more freedom a little bit
more capitalism in countries like China
and India has helped while everyone
there but disproportionately the poorest
people who were starving to death who
had incredible infant mortality rates
and we were talking about this form
we've seen them go down so I think Envy
is part of the cause of envy is wrong
moral views that people have moral views
that hold that the purpose of someone's
life isn't to achieve things in their
own life isn't to reach their own
happiness isn't to form a company like
Microsoft and get a computer on every
desk in the world running Microsoft
software if someone does that we think
he's selfish we think it's bad or at
least it's neutral and we envy him and
resent him if we're brought up to think
that way whereas if were brought up to
appreciate the people who created this
tremendous trust parity that both of you
were talking about and to see that as
morally good and as right and as
benefiting all of us but benefitting us
not because they did it for us
but because taking responsibility for
your life having gold having something
you want out of life leading a life of
your own on a grand scale a for your own
sake is what benefits not only you but
makes you a value to everybody else if
we had a society that understood that I
think that combats the envy and one of
the things that Rand wrote she had a
really interesting article called the
age of envy that talked about and also
another article called the untitled
letter which was a comment on Rawls and
she was very concerned about this kind
of egalitarian ISM and this kind of
growing Niall ISM and envy in the
culture it was she thought of it as
unamerican this isn't the kind of thing
this is more characteristic of Europe in
the 40
this wasn't an American way of thinking
but it was catching on here and I think
she was prophetic and I think we're
seeing a lot of that today so let's
shift a little bit because I know we can
talk about inequality and the individual
and all that we can we can do that all
night long but the the title of this
talk is philosophy and the human soul so
we only talked for literally about 20
seconds the four of us before you know
we didn't plan anything about what we
were gonna do here so I thought the best
way to start that would be how would you
even define the soul you're on I'll
start with you guys I was actually gonna
start with Jordan but you looked down
for a second which we Hugh that I should
go I mean I don't have I don't have a
definition of it but it has to do with
with consciousness and values it has to
do with with without conscious
experiences the some of our conscious
experiences of being in and the values
that we have as individuals the things
that are most important to us and that I
think experience is what I would refer
as our soul or spirit you know I think
these are somewhat interchangeable when
I talk about spiritual experiences it's
just it's an experience of consciousness
it's a you know if you listen to a piece
of music and the combination of emotion
values and and your conscious listening
and and absorbing that to me is what
spirit soul would mean it's great yeah I
would say speaking of the Philosopher's
and first as a random scholar gift she
had the the phrase that man as a being
of self-made soul so the idea here is
your soul is your consciousness as the
faculty your ability to know and to
think but also you have to build who you
are build your character build your
personality be
your values come to value things set
your life around them by doing that over
time and pursuing them you develop a
character you develop into a certain
type of person you develop into a
distinct individual there's a beautiful
line in the in The Fountainhead which
this is the theme of this conference
someone talks about how most people long
for immortality but when you meet them
the next time they weren't the same as
they were the last they're mutable
they're constantly changing what they're
after it's constantly changing but the
hero of the novel his friend says you
could imagine him existing forever he's
achieved immortality in his you know
day-to-day life because there's a
constancy to him and that kind of
constancy that having a soul having an
eye being a particular person it's an
achievement and it's the achievement of
having formed values having formed
something you want out of your life and
then having built for yourself through
living this way a character that's
adapted to that a character that's
focused on that you know this reminds me
of Groundhog Day in a way because in the
QAS that we've been doing for the last
couple months a couple times it's come
up what's your favorite comedy and
you've mentioned Groundhog Day where he
has to Bill Murray has to consistently
come back and do it better and do it
better and do it better and do it better
now I've set you up what is your
definition of well of the soul well I
was thinking that the words the hand
that writes and then moves on came into
my mind and then I was thinking well
this is the way I conceptualize how
consciousness works and so maybe this is
in some sense the locale of the soul so
I don't believe that we're driven
deterministically like obviously we are
to some degree but I don't think that
that's the right way of conceptualizing
how human consciousness works
I think it's putting the cart before the
horse in some sense so the way it looks
to me is that what we have a raid in
front of us is a landscape of
possibility and I think that that's
phenomenologically accurate you know
when you wake up in the morning
especially when you wake up at 3:00 in
the morning and you're you're concerned
about how your life is going you see an
array of possible futures manifest
themselves in front of you and you know
there are more possible futures of
course
than you can imagine but there's plenty
that make themselves manifest I could do
this I could do that this could happen
what about this maybe I should do this
and it's like there's a branching
landscape in front of you and some of
the places that you're headed to are
more likely than others and some of them
take a lot more effort to attain than
others but it's a distribution of
possible landscapes and that's actually
your reality it's not like you're driven
deterministically by the present you see
a branching landscape of possibility in
front of you and I think of that as
potential and we all know about
potential because we upgrade ourselves
and each other for not living up to our
potential which is a very interesting
thing that we do because potential isn't
something concrete and in fact it's the
opposite of concrete and yet we act as
if it's the most real thing you should
live up to your potential you know and
your conscience will bother you if you
don't live up to your potential so you
have a potential and there's a potential
that manifests itself and then what you
seem to do is that you make choices
between those alternative realities and
you do that in part by imposing a value
structure on them and and and deriving a
pathway as a consequence of that but you
decide which of those potentials are
going to manifest themselves in
actuality and so you are the hand that
writes that and then moves on and this
is a very deep idea I mean I've traced
it back to - I think our most profound
religious intuitions the idea that that
it was the Word of God for example that
gave rise to a habitable order out of
chaos at the beginning of time I think
is a reflection of the same idea I think
the soul is the thing that mediates
between potential and actuality and I
mean that literally and metaphorically
at the same time that's what you're
doing is you're confronting potential
which is that which could be and you're
deciding which of that is going to be
and the thing that's doing that is the
soul and that's it's divine task and I
think the fact that you do that is
actually why it's necessary for
societies to grant you the idea of
intrinsic right sorry no that's why it's
necessary for functional sister
societies to be predicated on the idea
that you have intrinsic
value is because you actually are the
locale where potential transforms itself
into actuality and so we determine the
actual that the action of our soul
determines the actuality of the world
I think that's genuinely the case so
this is really interesting to me because
I'm watching you guys and I can see a
lot of agreement but obviously Jordan
made at least two references to God and
religion there now obviously this is
where an Objectivist and Jordan would
have a point of disagreement this is why
you're doing these public events with
sam harris and one of the things that
i've been thinking about it as we've
been on tour is at the end of the day if
we all ultimately agree and if everyone
in this room if we could ultimately
agree on a morality and and the
definition of the soul that all made
sense and jordan's perhaps was had a
more religious connotation and yours did
in and we all could live functioning
good lives within that then does it
really matter beyond the the interest in
the intellectual discussion because
there was a lot of agreement i could see
it in your body language in both of you
guys Greg I'll start with you well let
me start with some of the things I agree
with a lot and including some of the use
of religious language I think there's a
good reason for even for those of us who
aren't religious or don't think of
ourselves as and I think I think of
myself as an atheist family but though I
know you I interpret that we're
different so first of all I think what
we've seen what you're describing about
the many manifold potentials and the
soul actualizes it is a convention which
I very much agree with I think we can
know is true and I think I agree we
presuppose and all of our thinking and
all of our judging of people which is
that we have free well that there's not
a future that's written in we're just on
a path traveling down at but rather in
every moment we're able to make choices
and our choices change the future and
that is a really profound fact it's a
profound fact about our consciousness
it's connected to everything else that's
of value about us and I agree if that
wasn't true of us we'd be a very
different kind of creature we wouldn't
interact with each others in the same
way
wouldn't need the same kind of political
structure and it's it's such a profound
fact about us that we don't really have
language for it or a very good language
for it religion has been the form in
which people have thought about the most
profound facts about their most profound
experiences about their understandings
of them from well from as long as
there's been people as long as it's been
anyway for a very very long time and the
V as we've lost religion
we haven't found ways or haven't always
found ways to conceptualize
independently of religion those kind of
profound values the profound role of
freedom and human rights the what our
highest potential is and so if you're
going to talk about those things it's
very hard to do it without really
reaching for at least religious metaphor
that that's a really crucial issue you
know I think I think it's a
fundamentally crucial issue what's true
but what's true matters right and
something can be a beautiful metaphor
but if understood literally is false and
one of the things I think we need to do
to lead our lives well to achieve these
kinds of values is to really value our
minds and value our reason and value
getting at the truth so if it turns out
that something's false
then believing that it's true is not
going to make our lives better and so I
don't think it could turn out that we're
gonna have a very deep disagreement
about what's true about the basic facts
of reality and yet we're all going to be
hunky-dory on everything else I think
those disagreements will make a
difference but we have to acknowledge
the role of consciousness and freedom in
life and I think there is an agreement
between us on that well what I've
observed is for example in my clinical
practice when when I'm talking about
life and death moral issues and and
these are in situations where extreme
things are happening in families and in
individuals lives talking about events
that might have
whose post-traumatic stress disorder or
that set people up for murder at times
their suicide like or care about
suffering some of which is induced
voluntarily the probability that I can
have a discussion with my clients about
that at a level that will be salutary
without using met religious /
metaphorical language is zero I can't if
I can't if the discussion can't take
place in the domain of good versus evil
something like that and this is
especially true I would say for
post-traumatic stress disorder you just
don't get anywhere with it and I've been
thinking about the the the narrative
issue a lot constantly and I think that
I know we we need to use this is this is
one of the weaknesses of the rationalist
argument I think is that we have to use
heuristics to operate in the world so
heuristics are simply are simplifying
maneuvers and we there's no option you
have to use heuristics and the reason
for that is because there is a lot more
world than there is of you and so you
take this incredibly complex reality and
you simplify it and now the
simplifications have to have merit and
and what makes them have merit is is
grounds for is a topic for a very long
lengthy discussion but to produce those
simplifications you have to use
heuristics you have to use cognitive
shortcuts and it looks to me like
narrative is a heuristic and that the
reason that we need to tell stories and
that we probably need to have our ethic
grounded in stories is because you can't
make a list of rules that will tell you
how to live rules don't suffice but you
can tell stories that are that lay out
broad principles and those are heuristic
principles no but the thing is is that
the most fundamental stories seem to
have a religious core now I'm not
exactly sure why that is although I
think it probably has to do with
something I referred to earlier which is
the idea that you know you are as a soul
you're the thing that transforms
potential into actuality that seems to
be the grounding concept in some sense
so that's the grounding concept there's
something divine about that out of that
arises a sequence of stories that are
shaped across for how
evolutionary history and inside that our
more articulated ethic exists and I
don't see a way out of that because you
cannot make an exhaustive list of rules
that enable ethical movement forward and
you need to do that if you had a purely
rational view of the way that human
cognition functions its so let's let's
pause right there can either one of you
figure out a way out of that I mean that
right that would be the the answer that
an Objectivist would wanna wanna have
right here we are we got a whole budget
right anybody so I don't think you could
have a list of rules if the ruler means
of like an algorithm that you ask your
life exactly and I think that's just not
something we can do that's not the way
the human mind works and the world is
complicated and you're not going to get
a bunch of if-then statements that take
you take you to me you can't even do
that for a lot of physical systems do it
right wrong but I think we can
understand them rationally I know this
might be similar to what we were talking
about in the green room about Sam
through of reason and yours and mine we
might figure out where they all lie but
I don't think reason is just about
coming up with algorithms I think we
come up with concepts concepts enable us
to assimilate vast quantities of similar
things to one another and learn from
future means about future instances from
past ones we can get quite subtle
principles but I think moral principles
are not things that take the form of
simple rules don't lie there to take
rands version of the virtue of honesty
which isn't don't lie it's it's your
recognition of the fact that what's
unreal is unreal and it can't be of
value so faking things won't work it
won't make them real somehow the thing
you fake it's gonna come back to haunt
you
that's not a simple rule of what to do
in each situation it's a kind of broad
fact that you can use to steer your life
by and in order to use it this year life
by and to fully understand it you need
to think about how it plays out in a lot
of different contexts right you need to
think about what it really means in
practice and art stories but you know
sure but also other forms of art I think
are an indispensable means to doing this
both with ethical truths like this and
also with other metaphysical truths
these about what kind of world we're in
so I guess part of the part of the
discussion and as it progresses will I
don't necessarily mean this discussion
in particular but you know obviously I'm
not an enemy of reason by any stretch of
the imagination
but I do see that it's hard for people
who promote reason as the fundamental
mechanism to distinguish between reason
and the generation of algorithms like
and you can say well my concept of
reason extends beyond the generation of
algorithms and fine but then my question
would be well exactly what are the
mechanisms by which reason functions
when what it's doing isn't generating
algorithms because algorithms aren't
enough and we know that right which is
why we don't have expert diagnostic
systems for example so then the the
reason starts to look something like
metaphor it starts to look something
like narrative and then I start thinking
yeah but that's not exactly the
Enlightenment concept of reason so we're
starting to move into a different domain
and so more than just algorithms and
metaphor and narrative I think first of
all one thing reason can do is come up
with metaphors and narratives but there
is more than just those three things
there's also think there's the formation
of abstract principles I don't think
what Newton did in writing the Principia
was coming up with algorithms there are
algorithms in it but or things you can
algorithmic eyes about how to prove
certain things but the act of forming
the concept inertia
that's not exactly you know that's
something else and I think it's a
inertia might be an algorithm yeah but
they acted they're coming up with
exampling yes and I think there's a
whole and under explored area of
philosophy and maybe cognitive
psychology thinking about what are these
acts of Reason how does the reason
function how is it that we can go from
the kind of information we have in
perception to a more and more
sophisticated understanding of the world
and and I've written some on this other
people have I don't know how much I
should try to explain here but I can
plug I have a chapter called
conceptualization and justification in a
book called concepts and their role in
knowledge that gives my sense of what
reason does here because here the other
thing that that's come up among the
cognitive scientists in particular
and also the robotics types is as as
people and this is Rodney Brooks in
particular who invented the room but by
the way but who's who's an absolute well
it's a major compliment because the
Roomba doesn't have a brain but it
operates intelligently like it's a major
accomplishment that thing and it took
Brooks Brooks actually reconstructed how
artificial intelligence robotics
engineers who were conceptualizing
intelligence and he thought of it as
something much more embodied rather than
conceptual so ISM the room was actually
the consequence of very very high-level
thinking about the relationship between
reason and and action in the world like
one of the things that caught the more
sophisticated cognitive psychologists
have been wrestling with is the fact
that a lot of what we thought of as
abstract reason is actually something
that's more dependent on embodiment than
we've ever had ever possibly conceived
right and so the idea of disembodied
reason which is also I would say an
Enlightenment concept seems to be
lacking it's lacking in functionality
you have to be embodied and the thing to
me is that an embodied reason looks to
me a lot more like the hero of a story
than it looks like disembodied reason I
think I think that's a better metaphor
and so partly why I like the idea of the
logos for example rather than the idea
of reason is because and and and this is
partly reflected in its in its
conceptual Christian origins because the
logos in Christianity is something
that's actually embodied right it's the
word made flesh there's a there's a
there's a link between the rational
logos logic and the thing that's
embodied and it's the interaction
between those two that produces I think
produces that phenomenon that you
described as what drove Newton for
example when he was producing his
algorithms that's not an algorithm but
it's something else
but it's not this is certainly not
disembodied reason but even that
metaphor of the word made flesh right it
sounds as though something that could
have been disembodied was disembodied
once and now it got embodied and so it
still sounds to me a little bit too much
like this disembodied conception of if
you want to call it reason or mind
whereas I think we want a conception of
what reason is and what it does that
involves the fact from
start that it's a feat of feature of
certain living organisms these organisms
have perceptual systems
those are bodily it anything is and it's
a a faculty of integrating the data
that's coming in through those those
organs helping us direct ourselves
through the world and then on a grander
and grander scale so I do think in the
Enlightenment what we're getting is a
lot of reflection for the first time or
for one of the first times a renewed
reflection on reason what it is how it
works and there are several different
views right some more materialistic
views like in the whole Bach and so
forth and then sees more the Cartesian
type views and I think most of the views
that came out of that are wrong and I
think it's it's sad because it's a
period when people were really valuing
the mind well they're productive Ryan
you're productive wrong well you know
because they got us somewhere else but
it certainly does seem the case that and
this is again I think the problem with
the idea of reason per se is that it's
it's not a sufficiently differentiated
idea to account for how it is that we
actually operate in the world and so and
and and and the AI types and the
psychologists are really tried to sort
that out but see one of the things that
happened to me when I was arguing with
Sam Harris about this because Sam
believes that you can derive values from
facts and more or less in an unmediated
way although he he he he has some
differences of opinion with himself
about how unmediated that is like it's
well I mean it's very difficult to be
entirely coherent when you think
something through something that's
complicated there's there's likely to be
inconsistencies in your argument because
it's so complicated but it looks to me
like it's actually formally impossible
to derive values from facts in an
unmediated sense you need something to
mediate between the facts and the values
and and then I would also say it looks
like it's impossible for you to derive
that structure merely over the course of
your life you don't have enough time
you're not smart enough and you don't
have enough time and so you have an
embodied biological platform or you are
that embodied biological platform and
it's actually the consequence of let's
say at least in part evolutionary
presser pressure is operating over about
a three point five billion year period
and so it's possible that you can derive
facts from values but it takes you three
and a half billion years to do it
properly and and and and what you have
that allows you to do that in your life
to look at a set of facts and to decide
how to proceed is the intermediation the
unconscious intermediation of that
unbelievably deep structure and when
I've said to Sam something that really
annoys him I said well you think you're
an atheist but you're actually not what
I'm actually saying is you're conscious
apprehension of yourself is a very thin
layer that's laid on top of what you are
because you don't know who you are and
most of what you do is unconscious and
that's actually an under and there isn't
a serious cognitive psychologist in the
world who doesn't think that most of
what you do is unconscious by the way
and I would say that unconscious has a
structure and that's a narrative
structure and that narrative structure
is deep and so that even if you describe
yourself as atheistic because in the in
the explicit content of your thinking
you see no room for the grounding of
your conceptions in divinity I would say
well that isn't how your unconscious is
structured at all
and now and you might object well how is
it structured yeah I think it's 99% of
you I think I've got a guy over there
with a slight objection he almost jumped
out of this chair alright how is your
unconscious structure which by the way I
think this is particularly interesting
because I think you have a lot of
agreements with Jordan on plenty of
stuff and I think you have a lot of
greement with Sam on planning stuff but
this is where this argument has gotten
down to it's a really really rich place
I think well I mean it's this is this is
the the the the big issue right so I
have agreements with Sam on stuff for
different but we have different reasons
for having that agreement and so for
example I agree with him in his art but
his conception of his art is very
different than our conception of his art
and he has no free will in that
conception so that blows my mind how you
can even talk about and is odd and
values without having free will and and
and he talks about choices without free
will which which
which is challenging we will do that we
might come to some certain agreement
about about I don't know rights or
something with children although I think
even now even our conception of Rights
is gonna be a little different because I
don't see how you can get to rights
without understanding the whole of
reason and and how recent functions and
what the enemy of reason ultimately is
which is which is what what I mentioned
earlier which is which is force so so I
think to go back to your original
question way back I think there's no way
for us to have different foundations and
not come up with different conclusions
we're going to have to come up with
different conclusions now we might agree
on certain issues in politics but for
example I think we're gonna disagree
quite profoundly on ethics right I think
you know just watching some children
things and on sacrifice and so on on the
role of Jesus or view of Jesus is gonna
be very very profoundly different and
that affects human behavior that affects
individual human behavior so they're
gonna be you can't start with different
premises and develop them and come up
with with exactly the same way and say
okay we agree on this stuff but no these
these things have profound consequences
the disagreements have profound profound
consequences now when I think of my
subconscious I don't think of it as this
this and again I'm not not a philosopher
not a psychologist so this is the way a
layman in these terms would think I
think of my sight of my psychologist my
subconscious not as a 99% darkness out
down there right I think of it as as as
something that accumulated information
conclusions values decisions that I've
made over since childhood since before I
was completely conscious of them that
they I have access to some of them you
know hopefully cognitive psychology you
know psychology can help me out get
access to more of them but they're
accessible to me they're not some
mystery they're accessible to me and
that when I am making a decision in life
I try to make it based on what I know
not based on what I don't know that's
back there right so I try to accumulate
facts this is the
- guy in me right over the reality guy
in me I tried to accumulate facts and
and and integrate them and and try to
distinguish between what if which facts
a legitimate and which facts the
illegitimate and try to integrate them
and and try to make a decision based on
logic based on based on reality and you
know sometimes my emotion will say and
this is my subconscious maybe speaking
don't do that oh that's a bad thing but
so what right if reality and the facts
are with me then I'll ignore that
subconscious so I don't see us as we've
got some choice over here but we're
really driven by the subconscious as
subconscious is there for me to explore
and I become a better person as I know
my subconscious better I understand
where my emotions are coming from and I
understand that better but at the end of
the day when I make a choice out there
it's based on reality in fact and see
then see and I see reality effects I
don't see anything coming between me and
this and this plastic bottle they again
a my simplistic view right there here's
that here's the plastic bottle I can see
it it's a plastic bottle and and it's
not something else not there's a lot
that goes into what is plastic what is
bottle what is that but but that's what
it is I can describe it I can actually
if I had the scientific knowledge get
down into the molecular structure and
it's real it's actually here it's not
created by consciousness or interpreted
by my consciousness it really is what it
is so I think what evolution has done
has given us those tools they ask you a
question show why is this why is the
stump in a beanbag both a chair well
because you're talking about myself
stump and a beanbag both a chair because
if you have a proper definition of a
chair then stomping a big bag both fit
that then what is the definition well I
haven't thought about it but you know
something to sit in that's it yeah so
it's something to sit on
yeah right that isn't inherent to the
object sure no truth see no but my
definition definitions are not inherent
in the object the the the objectively
created by you know my consciousness and
that object bring the object is an
object right it is a it is its
both of them are chairs and both of them
have a particular nature that is I can
describe both I can both say the stump
and the beanbag are the same there were
chair but I can also say the difference
the stump is made of wood and it has
this well let's say that the problem
with the idea that the object presents
itself is that two things are the same
and different in the near infinite
number of ways and that that's also a
technical problem so I could give you an
example so imagine that you're going to
classify a set of six books you're gonna
figure out how to arrange them in your
shelf you think well that's an easy
thing to do that's a conceptual problem
by the way it's actually not an easy
thing to do because there is an
indefinite number of ways that you can
classify a finite number of objects so
you can classify the books by color by
age by thickness by weight by a number
of ease by number of A's by number of
ease on the first page by number of
words by number of phrases this is
probably the question is why am i
classifying them so that is noise
there's no intrinsic value to
classifying books the question is why do
I want to classify them and the answer
to the why I want to classify them will
then determine how I classify absolutely
but that's exactly it but that's the rub
the rub is you see that's the rub your
classification system is dependent on Y
you apply it and that's exactly the
argument I've been using with Harris
which means the set of facts that reveal
themselves to you in the world are
dependent on your values Qasim's
argument is that the values are derived
from the facts it's like no wait a
minute there's an infinite number of
facts and they present themselves in
accordance with your values with your
with your purpose and so that that
demolishes the values from facts
argument now it makes it complicated
because there's an interrelationship
between like a causal interrelationship
but it is the case that your purpose
determines the facts that are a
themselves before you and that's
actually not disputable I would say no
the facts are the actual facts are the
actual fact is that I have six books and
actual fact is that there's a infinite
if you will way in which to order them
and it if I ordered them ie this would
so the facts all there where my values
introduced is how I'm gonna order them
but what the reason is there but no the
fact they might fire one they might be
firewood they might be a weapon yeah
there's lots of things they can be other
than books amusing to me because the
first no seriously though because the
first I study and I've written quite a
bit on concept formation and
classification but whenever I'm writing
but I don't think I've ever said this
before I remember back to when I was a
little kid and I had this bookshelf and
I was ordering the books on the
bookshelf and I was thinking well what's
the right way to do it and of course the
answer is that there isn't one right way
built into nature here's how everyone's
gotta put to the Dewey Decimal System
and if not for do we know one would have
figured it out right
there are a lot example a lot of
different ways you can order books but
there are also and anything else right
but there are also the facts about the
things that make it necessary to order
them in certain ways to achieve
different purposes right and to
understand as long as you have that last
part and phrase then there's very broad
types of purposes we have to have in
order to be able to think and function
at all um and those purpose is the
purpose of getting to know as much of
reality as we can of holding that
reality in a way that won't flummox us
and therefore this unit economical is
the word ran sometimes uses for this so
a way that allows you to hold a lot of
information in a compact number of units
and then there were certain facts we
need to know when other facts we don't
because of our nature's you know to
navigate ourselves through the world
provide standards for how we
conceptualize that yes so although our
purposes and our needs as human beings
matter it's not as though any purposes
just as good as any other and there's a
who you can come up with standards for
objectivity of what what is an objective
way to form concepts and to classify in
the same way that you can come up with
standard through what I don't think I
agree with everything you said except I
don't think you can come up with it
objectively
I even think there is a hierarchy of
values though
the sense of objective though that's
involved in objective grading or
objective reporting right it's not that
the grades already out there in the
paper and you just got to find it in
there or the newspaper story is already
written and a good reporter will find it
it's rather there's a way maybe not just
one but a small range of them right a
way that this has to be done in order to
accomplish legitimate purposes for doing
it yes there's a finite range of
organizing things that will enable you
to use them in an Radwell way what we
mean when we talk about an article being
written objectively a paper being graded
objectively and I think in the same
sense you could talk about a concept
being formed objectively or values being
formed objective but that I think is is
dead on like I do believe for example
that one of the ways we deal with the
fact that there's a plethora of facts is
that we impose interpretive structures
on those facts that are common to all of
us because we have common goals like we
don't want to suffer and die generally
speaking we want to stay alive and our
biological systems predispose us to act
in ways that are commensurate with that
and and so I don't think there's an
infinite number of solutions to the fact
that there's an infinite number of
problems that's where I think the post
modernists have gone wrong but I think
that when you say that what you've
produced by by constraining the solution
set is somehow akin to objectivity that
that's where I have a conceptual problem
even though I don't disagree with the
reason that you would make that case
because then I guess what would happen
is we'd have to define what constitutes
objective because when I think of
objective I think about the strict
application of the scientific method and
what that's done for us is lay out a
world not of values but of objective
facts if your objective you can lay out
the objective facts but I can't see how
you can derive the damn values even
though I do believe that there's a
hierarchy of values and that there's a
finite hierarchy I don't think putting
that into the category of objective
truth is reasonable because I don't
think that those truths are objective
there's something there's there's some
other form of truth well and I think
that that's generally captured in
something like metaphor and a narrative
which I think Dave's gonna push us to
move on in a minute well I think
I can before I actually wasn't I was
thinking that maybe we dumped the QA and
just keep going because I mean so first
I totally agree up one of these we won't
fully dump it we'll do about ten more
here one of these issues is how do we
define objectivity and this is another
one of these classifying questions right
and that's an interesting question where
does this concept comes from there's a
whole history to it there have been
books written about the history of the
concept objectivity and that's something
maybe for another occasion but let's
flag that as a really interesting
question as for just want to say
something about years off before we and
also something about whether we can get
to the same conclusion starting from
different places I see what Harris is
doing is he's in the tradition of a lot
of empiricists it goes back to Epicurus
it's definitely present in Mill and in a
different kind of way in Hume though
very different in Hume and Adam Smith um
if you're an empiricist you think
everything comes from perception and you
usually have a kind of fairly atomized
view of perception sequence collections
of sensations and what these types of
empiricists generally do when they get
to ethics is they pick some sensation to
identify their value terms with so
either pain may be the sensation of pain
is or since it could of suffering this
the one Sam users write is the bad and
then whatever the opposite to that
pleasure is the good some of them take
the sensation of desire fulfillment or
but they pick some sensation some simple
psychological state that can be
experienced in a moment and identify
that with the good and then they come up
with some theory about you know how do
we get as many of those moments through
as much of them as possible
that's famously with John Stuart Mill
does that but curious in a very
different way and if you think you can
derive values from facts like that I
don't think that's the mistake I don't
even think that's really deriving value
from facts all that's doing is
identifying values with certain very
very simple facts so what I think the
real question about deriving values from
facts is is we have these value concepts
concepts like good and bad that we use
to direct ourselves direct ourselves
through life how do we form these
concepts and I have
these concepts be formed based on facts
in an objective manner as opposed to
just being found out there already or or
just being made up and you can make up
yours and I can make up mine and there's
no way to tell if the Nazis or the Ku
Klux Klan or the Communists are we are
right about what the values are um so I
think you have to take this question
back to the broader question of how do
you form concepts and what kind of ways
does perceptual evidence play in the
forming of data and in the case of value
concepts and here I'm drawing on Rand if
I usually do what I think we do is at
the deepest level it comes from the
needs of living organisms there are
certain ways they need to function in
order to survive and prosper and values
are the way that we conceptualize that
the conceptual date of the sum of human
values in health in conceptual form is
an identification of something a human
being needs to live and he values it
insofar as he chooses to live and in
some form recognizes that it will
contribute to his life but what I think
ethics as a branch of philosophy as a
science in fact has to do is really
articulate the foundations of these
values where they come from what the
fundamental values are what the
fundamental ways of achieving them are
is so how do you guys think your
perspective from the perspective of our
Darwinian pragmatist let me just see one
more before I get to that so but that
doing that as a philosopher is a pretty
sophisticated thing people don't start
doing philosophy into thousands of years
more than that into living as human
beings this particular theory of the
origin of values didn't come about until
the 1950s
so in some sense prior to that human
beings were identifying things as values
in conceptual terms we learn it as we're
kids we learned that some things are
good and some things are bad and what a
philosophical theory of values has meant
to do is to articulate why that works
what it is that we're doing better when
we do that but other people who don't
have the same theory than us will have
some of the same values and so we might
come to the same conclusions but without
being able to fully defend and
articulate them in the same way I don't
think it's cool we never thought that
both of us think the Nazis were bad and
the Communists were bad even though we
start in some sense from different laces
but I think to fully develop and
understand
what's bad about them and to come out
consistently on the more difficult cases
of what's good and bad although the
Nazis was a really difficult case for a
lot of people we should remember and the
Communists deal is that's where we need
I think to get down to the no you're
asking me about the Darwinian approach
well because you know if you're if
you're making the claim which i think is
it's a it's a justifiable claim whether
or not it's accurate is that our ethics
are grounded in something like the
necessary can say the necessity for
survival and reproduction which are
variants of survival obviously it's a
Darwinian claim it's the claim that the
american pragmatists advanced as well
because this is this is person and
william james and primarily do we yet
you know they believe that your your
knowledge was a tool knowledge was a
tool to advance being in the world let's
say survival in the world and that you
justified your knowledge not because you
had finite final knowledge of anything
but because your tools were good enough
to obtain the end that you were aiming
at that was the validation process if
your theory was good enough to get you
to where you were aiming that it's it
was true enough and the pragmatist
believed that that was the best that you
could do with truth and then when darwin
advanced his theory the american
pragmatist said oh look darwin's theory
is actually an extension of pragmatism
and pragmatism is the notion that your
truths are good enough to facilitate
your survival but this is the rub it's
that's Darwin there's a there's a truth
that's embedded in the Darwinian
worldview that is not the same truth
that's embedded in the Newtonian
worldview there's a conflict between
those two and the Newtonian worldview is
basic basically the world of facts right
roughly speaking and there's a there's a
set of claims about truth that are based
in a Newtonian worldview and they're not
the same as the ones that are based in
the Darwinian point of view it's a big
problem and part of the reason that I've
been arguing with Sam for like three
years is because he's an evolutionary
psychologist in principle and about a
biological thinker and yet he
essentially has a Newtonian worldview
that it's the world of facts that's real
it's like no no there's a world of
values and the world of values is
devoted not toward
determining what's objectively true but
towards facilitating survival and those
are not the same thing now there's
obviously a relationship between them
because the world of values and the
world of facts Co exists but the
relationship doesn't seem to be
one-to-one I mean the world though other
values assumes the value of that is the
world of facts there are facts out there
that's the Newtonian physics there
really is a world out there they were
all facts of it values exist here exist
in the mind of individuals we value
something it's there are no values out
there independent on a value were so
these are two different dimensions any
any work you know they part of valuing
is identifying the facts yes this is a
rub funny even used your hand motions I
mean the kists are interesting
philosophically and and there are some
things I like about them and one is they
really stress the importance of activity
in thought you know thoughts don't just
the world doesn't just come to you to do
something to think right they really
stress the activity of the mind and they
really stress the role of ideas in
action and I think that's something
that's left out in a lot of philosophy
but I think they lose the reality in
doing that so they treat it as though
consciousness is just something that's
running your life and all your ideas are
just what your mind dizzy doing but I
think what we know and can tell to be
the case when we just introspect on our
own constant and think about what it is
to be conscious is that to be conscious
is to be conscious of something to be
conscious of something independent of
yourself there's a world out there and
what we mean by consciousness is the
grasp of an awareness of that world we
wouldn't even be able to get the idea of
our own consciousness except by contrast
to a world that we're distinguishing it
from you close your eyes and you open
them and you think the things still
there you know you have the idea of a
world
there and then your consciousnesses of
that world and I think you have to have
that idea of knowledge and knowledge
being about something that's independent
of you um and I think the pragmatists
lose that I think there's this kind of
dichotomy we find in thought between
everything's in your head and your minds
very active in your knowing the world
and you're deciding things and therefore
you don't actually get out the world the
way it actually is and then on the other
side you do get out the world the way it
actually is but because you don't do
anything it just comes to you passive
and I think both of those are wrong
there's activity you have to do to get
at the world but it's activity to get at
the way the world is and of course you
get it in a certain form just like if I
pick something up I'm holding it in one
form and I could hold it in a different
form you know but I'm still holding it
it's not like the pragmatists do retain
the world but they look at it slightly
different they say the world is what
objects to your stupid theory so let's
say you you so it's not that the world
is made of objects the world is made of
what objects to your stupid theory
that's a whole different idea and it's a
way more sophisticated idea so for the
pragmatist if you lay out a theory in
the world in action and the action
obtains it's and then the theory is
sufficiently true but you know lots of
times when you lay out your theory in
the world you don't get what you
expected and then the question is what
do you get and you might say well you
get an array of new facts it's like no
no that's not what happens what you do
what you get is an array of new
incomprehensible possibilities and
that's not the same thing as a set of
facts so let me give you an example
you'll all understand this very rapidly
imagine you're married to someone and
and you trust them and they betray you
and you discover that one day so that's
the world objecting to your stupid
theory that's for sure
because you had a theory about who you
were and the theory about who your
partner was and the theory about what
your life was and that theory was
seriously wrong past present and future
are all something radically new you
might say well a new set of facts
confronts you really is that right okay
just what are those facts it's like
you'll be in a pit for two or three
years trying to just get the bare facts
out of that situation the only thing
you'll know for sure when the world
objects to your stupid theory is that
you were wrong it's not like the world
is going to arraign it's it's like who
is this person that I was mayor
- that's what's going to be the question
and the question is what kind of fool
was I for making these presuppositions
to begin with and it's not like that new
knowledge will manifest itself in a set
of instantly apprehensible facts about
the true nature of the world you're
going to be suffering like mad for a
very good long time before you can take
what you have which isn't facts but just
confusion and transform that into
something that's even vaguely resembling
a set of apprehensible facts you'll be
in serious psychological trouble until
the world reira Veals itself as a set of
apprehensible facts and if you're
traumatized badly enough it'll never
happen and so that's another part of the
problem with the idea that the world
just represents itself as facts from
which you can derive values it's like
not when you're bloody confused and
you're confused a lot and you're
confused when the range of potential
that's manifested exceeds your your your
grasp it seeds your capabilities and
then the way you respond to that isn't
even cognitively the way you respond to
that this is part of embodied cognition
what do you do when something
incomprehensible objects to you well it
depends on how in comprehensible it is
but let's say what did you do when the
twin towers fell was it a set of facts
it's like you didn't know what the hell
was going on and neither did anyone else
what you did was go into a state of
crisis and that state of crisis is
actually an embodied precognitive
response and what happens biologically
is that you get flooded with cortisol
which is a stress hormone and what it
does is prepare you to take a very large
array of potential actions that's your
response so it's not like the world has
raid itself as a set of facts from which
you can derive value what happens is the
world's arrayed itself as an
incomprehensible mystery and you have to
do something about that and what you do
is ratchet up your physiology so that
you're burning yourself up because you
age faster when this sort of thing
happens which is why you age faster if
you're in crisis you burn yourself up in
the attempt to do everything at once to
prepare to do everything at once and
that's really the world manifesting
itself as an object and objecting to
your theory it doesn't come out as an
array of facts it would be so lovely if
every time you were wrong
what happened was a new array of facts
the point is that the reality doesn't
just show up it's not just an array of
facts but when that cortisol happens
when that if it happens what you do is
consciously make an effort to go find
the facts if for sure so the facts are
still in reality so something happened
in 911 so the first thing you do is what
actually happened you have to figure out
what actually happened there's real work
and real cognitive effort who are these
people
where did what is the ideology driving
them why did they do it all of these
things are facts that exist in reality
and your responsibility or my
responsibility I think to yourself is to
go find and discover the facts that are
relevant for the decisions and the
actions you need to take given the event
that's happened so yes psychologically
if you discover your wife's betraying
you you're confused that you but I think
your job as a human being is OK
what actually happened and where did I
make my mistake so who it's hard I but
this is what the certain mode of what
free will is free will is that engaging
reason engaging our consciousness to
discover the facts out there and and
apply them to making a new conclusion
right okay so so something's wrong in my
valuation of my wife what was it did she
really betray me are the facts true is
it is what's going on here real so all
of it is again of a turn to reason a
return to or so to return to discovery
effects which is what what reason does
okay so two things first you mentioned
relevant the the relevant facts and that
and that's the rub but I would also say
interestingly enough in relationship to
your argument the developmental
psychologist Jean Piaget made a very
similar claim he said that because the
domain of established facts was mutable
and that's the that's the issue say with
the fact that your partner could betray
you even what you know can be can be
mutable right then what is relevant in
the search for truth isn't the search
for a set of immutable facts but a
search for the process by which by which
facts are generated from the chaotic
potential to begin with it's not exactly
how Piaget worded it
but but the facts are there your wife is
either betraying you she's not betraying
you it's not it's not there's this
always a potential is also
potentialities but she's either
betraying you she's not between you and
your job is to discover whether she is
or she isn't right if that's the job
you've assigned yourself right so is so
it the reality is what it is it's not
dependent on your discovering it or not
your responsibility if you're married is
is to know whether your wife is between
you or not hopefully hopefully you don't
need to do the exercise coz because
she's not and and and and you have trust
in that but but your consciousness is
identifying the truth of what's out
there it's not some array of infinite
possibility she could be betraying she'd
be half betrayed you she can be half the
training it just like she can't be half
pregnant so they're two possibilities
she says betraying you she's not and
your job is to apply reason which I take
as identifying what is true and what is
not what is factual and what is not what
is the evidence weighing the evidence
and then there's a whole a psychological
assessment of that why did this happen
to me what did I see did I screw up did
she screw up why he was my assessment
before but that's a separate question
first did she or didn't you so so I it
strikes me as just this is relatively
simple right
the facts are what they are our job is
to discover them the world objecting to
your theory it's certainly true that the
world objects to stupid theories if
you've got them try it out but I don't
take that as a definition of the world
it's one fact about the world and more
importantly two facts about our theories
that they better match the world
otherwise we're going to have trouble
with them and when you get into this
situation and this is what I the
pragmatists take it too often is though
the theory is just there we're not too
interested in how it got there except by
repeated episodes of what's about to
happen which is that the world objects
to it and then you go scrambling to try
to get out of this state of cognitive
dissonance that you're in because of the
objection so you know Dewey says at one
point thoughts of disease right
everything's easy and nice you don't
have to think you just go by in some
stupor he wouldn't put it that way but
and then some fact of Jackson now you
for the world of
Jaxson now you've in dissonance and you
gotta figure out how to reconfigure your
mental life so that you can get on with
it and that is what a lot of people did
after 9/11 right a lot of people
something unexpected and horrible
happened and what they were motivated to
do was figure out what are the fewest
moves I can make to get things to go
back to normal and be all right I don't
care what's true I don't care who really
did this I don't care what would really
solve it I just care what I can tell
myself to make this confusion and
disruption and agitation go away and
that's dishonesty and that's wrong and
to really value honesty and wanting to
get the right answer and being rational
in these situations and caring about
what happens to your damn life you can't
say you know oh I just want to be back
into blissful oblivion by coming up with
some new theory why do you think why
didn't happen I saw what went wrong in
the first place I got to this theory
somehow yeah now I see that the theory
is wrong what mistake did I make along
the way what was the process by which I
generated this theory and what was the
misstep in that process how can I fix it
to generate a new theory one that'll be
true and that that process by which you
generate your theories it's a process of
forming concepts it's a process of
collecting evidence it's a complicated
process it's a lot to say about it right
sounds like repentance and atonement to
me it can be but it's in that you're
acknowledging an error and you're trying
to fix it but you're trying to see how
you made this theory and how you can
make it better and if you this idea that
you know this idea that philosophy and
real thinking starts when you come to
contradictions you get this back in the
Greeks with the dialectical tradition of
people debating each other and I think
there's something really profound in
Aristotle as opposed to the Plato and
the other Greeks the the other Greeks
they seem to and then later Hegel they
come up with contradictions and they
think what can we do to get past this
contradiction but what Aristotle always
does and all of his books have this
structure I think it's brilliant he he
gets into a field by discussing the
debates in it he shows all the
contradictions and all the puzzles and
it can't be this in this and then he
says let's start fresh let's go back to
the drawing board let's think about how
we got here and then he crafts a new
theory starting from the kind of fact
that motivated the old series from the
kind of observation
say that motivated beyond theory but
that avoids the difficult isn't anyone
rather than just trying to reconfigure
to go forward you go back and if there's
a hierarchy not just a hierarchy of
values but also a hierarchy of our
understanding of the world certain ways
of understanding it are more basic and
others are built up on top of that when
you find that one of your theories and a
theories are really complex way of
knowing like when you find that one of
your theories is mistaken you think how
can I go back to the more basic more
primitive types of knowledge more basic
types of observations whatever it might
be from which I generated this theory
and then and now add to it the new
observations and the new knowledge that
I have based on what went wrong and
generate a new theory that will be
better than it yeah let's give Jordan
the last word okay well yes but well but
there's a crook the problem is you know
it that works
hmm there's there's two problems with it
though one is that it's really really
really really difficult
cognitively because the more of your
theory you have to unpack like imagine
that your theory is composed of of
presumptions and the more basic the
presumption the more your world is
organized as a consequence of that
presumption and so like the presumption
of your partner's fidelity is a very
fundamental presumption because the
entire interpretation of your
relationship is predicated on that
assumption and so if you let that
assumption go then you let everything
that you know about your relationship go
and that casts you into chaos more and
more thoroughly so the more you go back
to first principles to revise your
theory the more cognitive I don't like
this the net distance idea but the more
you throw your state yourself into a
state of existential crisis and the more
you end up psycho physiologically
preparing for catastrophe as a
consequence and the faster you die so
the problem with unglued things back
down to first principles which is
actually what happens to people by the
way when they develop post-traumatic
stress disorder is that you undo
yourself in doing that and when you undo
yourself there's a physiological price
to pay so even though that is the root
out make a fundamental error you should
make fundamental reparations the cost of
doing that is unbelievably high and so
people are loathe to do
even though they might have to do it
because of course you know you were
saying it was wrong to paper over an
error and I asked what why is it wrong
if it makes you feel better why is it
wrong which is a perfectly good question
but the answer to why it's wrong is well
what do you you want to make the same
stupid error again what if the error was
quasi fatal you make it two more times
you're dead and so the cost of repeating
that's the thing about cognitive errors
insofar as they're enacted if they're
errors and you make them in the world
the world objects and it takes you apart
and if there is profound enough then you
suffer a lot and die and maybe not just
you like the errors can be really
profound so it might be that you have to
fix the damn hole in your map because
otherwise you'll fall through but that
nonetheless that the cost of doing that
is so high that you're going to shy away
from it and people do that all the time
that's partly why they take the easy
route it's like they take the easy route
because the difficult route is it's
difficult it's really difficult well
I'll think about what you'd have to
figure out if you were subject to a
betrayal like that it's like well maybe
you married the wrong person that's Paul
so well maybe you created the wrong
person in your marriage in your
interaction interactions with your
partner or maybe you're so damn naive
that it's just absolutely beyond
comprehension like there's all sorts of
terrible things lurking under the
revelation of that objection and digging
down there too to pull them out is it's
a hell of a job right that's the
confrontation with the terrible dragon
of chaos and in that confrontation you
can easily be burnt to a crisp so but
this is partially why it's so it's so
crucial to know yourself and to build a
solid foundation of self in any
relationship right so that so that it's
not somebody else's betrayal does not
unwind everything you think about
yourself so you you can't go that every
time reality doesn't match your theory
you completely unwind right so so
knowing one's self having a solid
foundation a sense of you know sense of
self-esteem a sense of self-worth or
self sense of confidence
and having a philosophical phonation and
this is why as you said it's hard work
and and that we agree completely that is
morality is hard work
living is hard work you went back to to
the idea of the pragmatism and survival
one of the things that that we you know
that I hold it you know we hold I think
is that survival qua you man being as a
human being with their unique features
as human being it's a lot of work and it
were quite particularly type of work
particularly reasoning and thinking and
figuring stuff out and the more work we
do the more we build our character the
easier it is to deal with these shocks
to the system the easier it is to deal
with the 911 or more betrayal because we
know what we are and now we just need to
figure out what the facts on we can deal
with whatever the facts are whatever
reality throws at you if you've done the
mole work to create a mall character you
should be able to deal with well you
have your best shot
well I got a seriously stiff neck from
looking that way yeah well I this was
such a perfect example of why I love the
reality that I like to think I created
and maybe some of it came from before me
too because this is it I mean what do
you think was more worthwhile what we
just did here for an hour or what was on
CNN for the last day you know this
really is it and you know these are
these are huge differences and in some
ways they're small differences and
that's what I want to end for our final
five minutes here is why is it that so
seemingly these days so few people are
willing to do this so few people are
willing to tour the country to talk all
to all sorts of people about all sorts
of different things and put their ideas
on the line and and do all the
philosophical work that you do and
you're on you also travel the world and
it seems there's an absolute starvation
for it and yet so few people are doing
it you're on I'll start with you and
they'll go this way I mean I think
because those people who don't want to
have the debate have no ideas that
they're really empty then he lists in
some cases and in that case what is
Niall ism Niall ism is the absence it's
a zero a nothing called it the worship
of zero right
it's a nothingness it's it's it's the
they don't stand for anything what are
they gonna go and and and do debates
when they don't really represent
anything other than destruction there's
nothing to talk reason doesn't matter
ideas don't matter speech doesn't matter
as a consequence so it matter is action
this is why auntie pho storms into a
room and you know they they use their
fists like there's nothing for them to
say there's no value that they have to
present and I think it's true on and if
you will and under on the on the rights
under non speech right it's the same
thing it's my revelation my River you
know Islam or Christianity or whatever
the religion is it's my revelation it's
nothing to debate
the truth is revealed to me you know
there's no logic there's no reason
there's no rationality that can
challenge the fact that God spoke to me
through a book or whatever the way he
spoke to me and this is the truth and
there's nothing else that can be
discussed so you've got on two sides all
they have is emotion and action reason
ideas debate discussion as soon as you
band and reason as soon as you abandon
the idea that conversation that logic is
the way in which we debate discuss and
discover the truth then now you've a
banded speech right so ya against free
speech because they're against reason
because they're against reality
isn't that really the beauty of this
it's not that there has to be a knock
out here that somebody has to be you
know dragged offstage it's that everyone
although wait for the closer but what
that really that everyone here the the
600-cell my people here can take what
they've heard hear and then start
applying their own logic and reason and
figure out what what they believe one
thing I only think and say to my
students in that connection is that you
know minds are rarely changed in the
course of an argument that doesn't mean
they're not changed by an argument but
you know if you and I are having an
argument now it's it's about something
important and deep it's very unlikely
that one of us at the end of the 15
minutes were arguing is gonna come away
with a changed world view it happens
occasionally but pretty rare but often
you know you go home you think about it
I think about it and both of us improve
our thinking as a result of that and
maybe sometimes you see profound changes
over time the other thing I wanted to
say to your comment about why don't we
see more of this a wire and people
willing to go around the country and do
these kinds of talks and and it does
seem like there's a hunger for it people
are turning out one important thing with
products and you know this is a product
that we're creating here right for
people to consume is there's a lot of
times in the world when there is a
potential demand for a product and
people who could create that product and
nobody notices it and it goes a long
time with nobody noticing and what's
what's great about entrepreneurs is
they're the kind of people who notice
that there's an opportunity for this
they figure it out and they create
something new and I think that's what
you're doing here right you probably
would have been willing to go on a tour
a couple of years ago and you know Iran
would but before it was proven that
there were these people who want to hear
this and there are ways to connect them
together nobody would have known to do
it and so what all of you guys are doing
in this connection and particularly Dave
what you're doing and bringing all these
people together on these long-form talk
shows I think is fantastic
and it's creating this kind of value and
I see it as one of the things that one
of the hopeful signs in the culture
that's combating the signs that Iran
talked about on both political sides
you can either take us out soft or go
for the kill the choice is yours
there are very friendly group of people
well look I mean if you're gonna talk
about if you're gonna dare to think
publicly about difficult things to think
and speak publicly about difficult
things then you're going to cause
trouble because you can't talk about
something difficult without causing
trouble
if it was easy that everyone would agree
and then you could talk about it no one
would care cuz everyone already knew but
it would be easy but if it's difficult
and you talk about it then you're gonna
upset people and then when you upset
people they're gonna yell at you a lot
and then well that's what's gonna happen
and then you know if you're not sure
that there's any support for your
position or even if you're sort of
vaguely human and it upsets you to be
yelled out by many many people you know
you tend to shut up if a whole bunch of
people are yelling at you because you
might be wrong and also you might be in
danger but but what happens right now is
that well two things one thing to know
is that just because some people yell at
you right now doesn't mean that all
people will yell at you over the next
month right so the people who are being
thoughtful about it are going to be
quieter and they might be sort of hiding
in the woodwork and so you have to learn
that but then the other thing is and
we've talked about this quite a bit in
this tour is that there's a
technological revolution that's
occurring that's enabling these
long-form conversations and it wasn't
possible before like we can livestream
this right for no cost and so a whole
bunch of people can watch this and the
technology's there and it turns out that
the technology has revealed to us the
fact that there's a collective
starvation for deep long-form discussion
and so hooray for that and so maybe that
niche will be increasingly filled it's
it seems to be happening and so and that
would be a good thing because it seems
to me that the way out of our current
state of idiot political polarization is
isn't the final establishment that one
side is right and the other is wrong but
to engage in sophisticated long-form
discussions to deal with the actual
problems that are producing the
polarization and maybe we can do that
and maybe this is part of the
by which we do that successfully that
would be a testament to the utility of
the reason that you were describing
which is the only alternative to
subjugation or violence right we either
talk it through we capitulate or we
tyrannize those are the options
well
on that note keep it going for talking
it through and for these three guys who
presented their right is thank you guys
for coming out thank you for watching on
the YouTube
[Applause]